Speaker 1: Not shockingly, much of the controversy
around vaccine requirements is dramatically
exaggerated by people looking to get attention,
people looking to fundraise, people looking
to fearmonger, people looking to play the
victim card.
Most Americans support vaccine requirements
for workplaces, classrooms and sporting events,
period, but just a majority.
When I say most, I mean a majority.
Now, I don't say this because I think that
just because something is popular, it should
be the law.
I don't there was a point where a lot of people
thought gay marriage shouldn't be legal, that
didn't mean that that's what it should be.
You don't put everything to a vote.
But I say this because there is not nearly
the controversy over vaccine requirements
that some want you to believe there is.
So the numbers from a new CNN poll overall
for every day activities, only 51 percent
favor versus 49 percent oppose vaccine requirements.
That's a very, very small it's basically within
the margin of error, 50/50.
But when you say what about vaccine requirements
for places of work, 54 percent are in favor.
The other 46 percent are split between against
and being unsure.
54 percent say vaccines should be required
for places of work.
Fifty five percent say vaccines should be
required for in-person classes.
required for sporting events or concerts,
comparatively, only 41 percent say vaccines
should be required for the grocery store.
That's predictable.
That that's that's not shocking to me.
Also, every month that this poll is done,
support for these vaccine requirements goes
up.
And I anticipate that the numbers will be
even higher in terms of support for these
vaccine requirements in another month.
So this is not overwhelming support.
It's not like after Sandy Hook with universal
background checks, 88, 90 percent of the country
said we need universal background checks.
We still couldn't get it done, by the way.
But it's a slight majority, whereas right
wing media would have you believe this is
tyranny over which the entire country is outraged.
That's just not the case.
Part of the reason why support continues to
increase for these requirements is that the
virus is spreading and things are really,
really bad in much of the country.
If everyone were vaccinated, it would effectively
reduce the total public health burden of covid
down to about the level of the flu.
We don't have that.
The unvaccinated are burdening the health
care system to such a degree that there's
very little choice left.
But for Joe Biden to try these ideas, this
sort of spreading anti vaccine tourism that
has infected so many is a virus of itself.
It's its own infection.
And let's be honest, when we say more than
half the country supports most of these requirements,
it's mostly Democrats, a fair number of independents
and a very small number of Republicans.
Public health has become partizan.
Science has become partizan.
You don't like the science to pretend that
science is just an opinion and come up with
a different one.
That's a real tragedy that we're experiencing.
And unfortunately, although we are dealing
with it to a far greater degree than most
other countries, it's actually starting to
infect some other countries as well.
And we're going to talk more about that a
little bit later on in the program.
Let me know if you favor vaccine requirements
for work concerts, grocery stores.
You can find me on Twitter at Pakman and let
me know your thoughts.
We have so much to cover today that I will
take only the minimum amount of time to remind
you that we are funded by memberships and
you can get a membership at join Pakman Dotcom
today, only use the coupon code.
No recall, no recall in California.
That's what we're talking about.
The California gubernatorial recall is today.
You'll get a 70 percent discount at join Pakman
Dotcom.
No recall.
That's the code.
All one word, all lowercase.